جامعات ايران تنتفض ضد النظام ومحتجون
يضربون النار بمقر للبسيج في محافظه
بوشقران
تركيا تعلن قتلى 22 مصلحا خلال يومين من
العمليات العسكريه شمال سوريا والعراق
وتتواعد بمواصله العمل
32 ومخاوف من نقص كبير في مصادر الطاقه مع
توقعات بعاصفه ثلجيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الى اهم الانباء من العربيه البدايه
من احتجاجات ايران حيث خرجت مظاهرات في
عدد من الجامعات تحديدا بممارسه النظام
القمعيه واحتجاجا على وفاه الشابه
امير كبير لتكنولوجيا بالعاصمه طهران
نظامه الله باعتصاما احتجاجا على اعتقال
السلطات عددا من زملائهم في جامعه العلامه
بالعاصمه ايضا زين طلاب في كليه الاداب
كليتهم برموز برتقاليه بمناسبه اليوم
العالمي للقضاء على العنف ضد المراه كما
نشرت وكاله انباء حقوق الانسان
ضد سلطات الايرانيه
بدوره اكد اتحاد طلاب المنظمات الاسلاميه
ان طلبه جامعه العلوم وثقف بطهران نظم
احتجاجا تضامنيا مع ابنائي محافظه كردستان
وندد بقتل قوات الامن للمتظاهرين في
المحافظه من جانبها شهدت جامعه خوارزمي في
محافظه البرز مسيره طلابيه تضامنا مع
ابناء محافظات ايرانيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما اضرب محتجون النار في مقر البسيج
بمدينه برزان في محافظه بوشهر وحرقوا صوره
لقاسم سليمان في مدينه قرتك جنوب طهران
بانيت
[موسيقى]
اطلقت صراحه نجمه كره القدم الايرانيه
ولاعب المنتخب السابق ماريا غافوري
اهانه المنتخب الايراني لكره القدم
وفي كندا افادت هيئه الاذاعه الكنديه بان
كنديين من اصول نيراليه يتعرضون للتهديد
والمراقبه من قبل اعضاء تابعين للنظام
الايراني موجود هنا في كندا ذكرت الهيئه
ان بعضها اولي المعارضين ابلغوها انهم
تلقوا تهديدات عبر مكالمات هاتفيه ورسائل
نصيه حضارتهم من تناول الاوضاع في ايران
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قال المتحدث
باسم المخابرات الكنديه
ان التهديدات الايرانيه
النظام كما تقوضه ان وسياده البلاد
ومن لايف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وزاره الدفاع التركيه
من حزب العمال الكردستاني شمالي سوريا
والعراق خلال اليومين الى خيرين من
العمليات العسكريه وقالت وزاره الدفاع
التركيه في بيان نشراته على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي سوريا
اقامه حزام امني من الغرب الى الشرق على
طول الحدود الجنوبيه لتركيا لابقاء الحدود
امنه هدف انقره التي تشل سلسله غارات جويه
على شمال شرق سوريا ومواقع لمقاتلين اكراد
يقول الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
المنطقه الامنه ستسمل بحكم الامر الواقع
مدينه كوباني او عين العرب التي انزعتها
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في العام 2015 من
تنظيم داعش بدعم من الولايات المتحده
الامر الذي ردت عليه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في حديثا للعربيه مؤكده ان
المنطقه الامنه هي امنه فقط لتنظيم داعش
بدعم تركي تركيه هي لم تكن موثوقه بالنسبه
لتحالف الدولي منذ عام 2014 بسبب علاقتها
الواضحه مع تنظيم داعش الارهابيه نحن
شاهدنا والعالم مشاهده
البوابات
وجرابلس واعزاز مفتوحه بين داعش دوله
تركيا
التي تنوي انقر القيام بها اكدتها اسد
مشدده على انها بكامل جهوزيتها لصديق اي
هجوم بري والدفاع عن المنطقه وسكانها
واشنطن جددت معارضتها الشديده لشن تركيا
عمليه
تلوح بها منذ ايام شمالي سوريا وطالبت
انقره بوقتها لانها تهدد امن الجنود
الامريكيين الموجودين في مواقع لقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه في المقابل اعربت روسيا
عن املها بعدول تركيا عن تنفيذ عملياتها
العسكريه البريه واعتبرت ان لا احد يريد
تصيد التوتر
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد السوداني بحث
في بغداد مع رئيس الاتحاد الوطني
الكردستاني
للامن الوطني العراقي اعلن الاربعاء
الماضي
على طول الحدود مع ايران وتركيا عقب اعلان
الحرس الثوري الايراني
في اقليم كردستان العراق
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد قليل
رئيس كوريا الشماليه يسعى لان تكون بلاده
اكبر قوه نوويه في العالم
اهلا بكم من جديد
عن مقتل مالا يقل عن 32 شخصا في منطقه
خرسون جنوب افريقيا
قال قائد الشرطه الوطنيه
دائره الارصاد الجويه في كيبا فازت
باحتمال تعرض العاصمه الاوكرانيه الى
عاصفه ثلجيه كثيفه بدءا من اليوم الاحد
وحتى منتصف الاسبوع مع درجات الحراره
المتوقعه قد تصلوا الى درجه التجمل وحضر
مسؤولون عن عمليات توريد الطاقه بان
الاوضاع ستكون صعبه في كيب في ظل نقص شديد
في امداد الطاقه وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي
وتعرض البنيه التحتيه للقذف الروسي الذي
طال مناطق عده وتسبب في انقطاع الماء
والكهرباء عن نحو سته ملايين شخص وفقا
لتصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني
وفي رياضه كشف سفير الاوكراني
بترونوكو اناتولي ان القوات الاوكرانيه
اعترضت اكثر من 400 طائره مسيره ايرانيه
مؤكدين على ان الحكومه الاوكرانيه تعمل
على تصعيدي ملف تزويد ايران لروسيا
بالطائرات المسيره للامم المتحده لفرد
عقوبات اضافيه على طهران
شامله عن الدوري الايراني في الحرب على
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك الجانب المتعلق
بالشاحن ونعرف كيف وصلت المواد اليهم وكيف
استخدموها في استهداف المدنيين والبنيه
التحتيه كما اننا على درايه بالمواصفات
الكيماويه والتقنيه لتلك المسيرات وعند
مواجهه اي تخوف فاننا نتعاون مع شركائنا
الدوليين بمصداقيه وشفافيه
امام الامم المتحده لتسليط الضوء عليها
ايران لقيامها بتزويد روسيا بهذا السلاح
باستخدامه ضد اوكرانيا
عريضه من المجتمع اليمني بسبب سيطره
الحوثيه وتعنتها في سماح بتسليم المساعدات
الغذائيه والانسانيه لمستحقها
الارقام التي تقدمها التقارير الامميه
تعكس صوره سوداويه للاوضاع في اليمن
[موسيقى]
في كل مكان السلاح متوفر اما الطعام فلا
اليمنيون واليمنيات يتدورون جوعا حسب صور
انتشرت مؤخرا عبر الانترنت
واشارت لها جريده الشرق الاوسط في تحقيق
لها عن الوضع الماساوي في اليمن
المشهد يبكي كل من له قلب بينما الحوثيون
يعيشون رغد العيش
وبدرماتهم تعفنت من كثره الاموال المقدسه
وهم مستمرون بالمتجر بمعاناه الشعب اليمني
بكل قبح وخبز واجرام
كما ان الجماعه دابت على الاستحواذ على
المساعدات الغذائيه الاتيه من ميناء
الحديده حيث يتم تحويلها لاتباع الجماعه
وبالتالي لا تستفيد منها الفئات الاكثر
تضررا
الحوثيون اضافه الى فرضهم الاتاوات على
المواطنين بادروا بزياده الضرائب
والتعريفات الجمركيه على التجار اجراء
تسبب برفع اسعار المواد الاستهلاكيه في
بلد انقطعت فيه رواتب الموظفين الحكوميين
منذ سته اعوام في المناطق المسيطر عليها
من قبل الحوثيين
سعيا لمعالجه الاسماء يهدف برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه الى ايصال المساعدات الغذائيه
الى حوالي 13 مليون من اليمنيين هذا العام
ويعد معدل سوء تغذيه الاطفال في اليمن من
اعلى المعدلات في العالم حيث يحتاج
مليونان ومئه الف طفل دون سن الخامسه الى
العلاج من سوء التغذيه الحاد العربيه
[موسيقى]
نقلت وسائل اعلام الرسميه عن زعيم كوريا
الشماليه
لبلاده هو امتلاكه اقوى قوه نوويه في
العالم
بناء القوه النوويه يهدف لحمايه كرامه
وسيادته الدوله
استراتيجيه في العالم القوه المطلقه التي
لم يسبق لها ما فيل خلال القرن على حد
لليوم الرابع على توالي تسجل الصين
ارتفاعا حادا في عدد الاصابات بيكورون حيث
اعلنت السلطات المحليه عن تسجيل نحوي 40
الف اصابه جديده خلال ساعات الماضيه في
حين قالت سلطات في مدينه
الصين انها ستحد بالنسبه اشغال المطاعم
والاماكن المغلقه الاخرى الى 50% في اطار
تدابير سياسه صفر قبل في الصين
قالت السلطات في تشيلي ان بركان فيلا ريكا
في جنوب البلاد زاد من نشاطه وبدات الحمم
البركانيه تظهر على سطحها وظهرت لقطات
مصوره بطائره بدون طيار البركان المشتعل
وهو يقذف الحمى من قيمته المغطاه
[موسيقى]
في خطاب النشر هذا التذكيره بابره العالم
تنتفض ضد النظام ومحتاجون يضربون النار
تركيا تعلن قتل اثنين وعشرين مصلحها خلال
يوم من العمليات العسكريه شمالي سوريا
والعراق
بمواصله العمليه
32 وما خوف من نقص كبير في مصادر الطاقه
خلال شتاء
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]